what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and although unfortunately the
production for Deadpool 3 is delayed
right now due to the strikes we have
some amazing news and further details
about Wolverine and Deadpool in Deadpool
3 specifically about how they actually
meet in the movie now there has been a
lot of speculation about how this could
possibly happen plus not to mention in
the end in the post credits for Deadpool
2 Deadpool got Cable's time travel
device and went back in time and he
interacted with Wolverine and although
we're pretty sure this post-credit scene
is going to play a pretty important
factor in Deadpool 3. it doesn't look
like the Wolverine that is going to be
teaming up with Deadpool and Deadpool 3
is that same Wolverine from the post
credits however it does appear that the
Wolverine that is going to be in
Deadpool 3 is indeed from the fox
universe but keep in mind there are
Brands timelines and there are many
different variants of that same Fox
Universe Wolverine but it does appear
that Wolverine is going going to at
least know who Deadpool is we're unsure
what their history is going to be
together but today it looks like we
found out two extremely important
details about Deadpool 3 and one of them
is how Wolverine and Deadpool meet will
break both of these things down in this
video of course and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Deadpool 3 and
Marvel news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment down below you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so yesterday some news came out
about Deadpool 3 possibly involving the
comic story of battle World we'll
explain what this is and talk about how
Dr Doom could possibly make a cameo in
Deadpool 3 later on in the video but as
far as Deadpool and Wolverine meeting go
battle world is actually going to play
kind of a key role this morning Insider
Casey Walsh tweeted this Deadpool 3 is a
lead up to Secret Wars realities are
collapsing and the TVA is picking heroes
from these dying worlds to put them in
the one Universe the new Earth slash
battle World Wolverine is chosen from
the fox universe and finds an imprisoned
Deadpool and they start their Adventure
so this is a little bit more information
about how battle world is going to play
a role in Deadpool 3. it looks like the
TVA is actually going to kind of be
responsible for battle world this is
obviously different from the comics and
like I said we'll talk about that in a
bit but it does explain how Wolverine
and Deadpool do come in contact with
each other and find each other he states
that Wolverine is going to find an
imprisoned Deadpool and this goes back
to that post-credits scene from Deadpool
2. Deadpool did a no no he went back in
time and he altered events that is
exactly what triggers the TVA that is
exactly what Loki did in Loki season 1
when he escaped with the Tesseract that
was not supposed to happen so we can
safely assume that Deadpool getting
Cable's time travel device was not
supposed to happen him going back in
time and killing the other Deadpool
version of himself was not supposed to
happen and especially him interacting
with that Wolverine variant was not
supposed to happen either so I think
it's pretty safe to assume that at some
point in time the TVA goes and captures
him but instead of pruning him they
actually take him prisoner and this
could be because all of these other
worlds all of these other universes are
indeed starting to collapse Casey Walsh
states that Deadpool 3 is a lead up to
Secret Wars which we knew but a lot of
people don't realize just how quickly
Deadpool 3 is going to go into Secret
Wars it pretty much comes out right
before Avengers Kang Dynasty and we know
that in Kang Dynasty the Multiverse is
essentially going to collapse prior to
that it's going to start collapsing in
fact it already has incursions have
already begun we learned that in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
then at the end CLIA appeared and said
that doctor strange caused an incursion
and they went to go fix it and
apparently in Doctor Strange 3 we're
going to learn that many other
occursions have been happening so the
Multiverse right now has already begun
to collapse so Deadpool 3 is really
going to start to show that we know Loki
season 2 is going to take this even
further essentially showing the
Multiverse collapsing and showing tons
of different branched timelines
appearing and tons of different variants
of King the Conqueror because remember
the Multiverse collapsing is due to
several different things not just one
thing yes it is due to incursions caused
by people in certain universes but it's
also due to King the Conqueror trying to
conquer the Multiverse and starting
multiversal Wars with universes so they
are destroying universes and causing
incursions that way as well so it could
be at this point in time the TVA could
be collecting Heroes to possibly fight
against Kang why would the TVA be
collecting Heroes and putting them in
one Universe well that could be a reason
and another reason could be that Kane
the Conqueror himself is actually
collecting these Heroes possibly to use
for his own will or simply his own
pleasure but more on that in a bit so we
assume Deadpool gets captured by the TVA
due to him time traveling at the end of
Deadpool 2 and that's where where
Wolverine finds him it might be safe to
assume that Wolverine knows who Wade is
that's why he finds him and releases him
either that or he finds him and Deadpool
simply convinces Wolverine that in
Another Universe they knew each other
actually in several other universes they
knew each other and they were well I'm
sure Deadpool would say they were best
buds when in reality of course he would
drive Wolverine crazy but Casey Walsh
says this is where they start their
Adventure now as far as battle world is
concerned this is a little bit different
than what we were thinking about however
it is kind of comic accurate here a
little bit at least in the secret Wars
battle World Comic storyline Dr Doom
takes the power of the beyonder and he
takes a bunch of different shattered
realities and universes and he puts them
all together and he forms battle world
he then rules over it with Dr Strange at
a side and the Thor Corp doing the work
for him there are quadrants or regions
on Battle world and people are not
allowed to leave the regions or the Thor
core will show up now eventually in the
comics they strip the power away from
God Emperor Doom the beyonder gets his
powers back and ultimately the
Multiverse gets restored and that's why
I think we could possibly see a Doctor
Doom cameo in Deadpool 3 however I don't
think it would be a new actor playing
the new Doctor Doom I think it would be
probably be the old actor Julian McMahon
that we know as Dr Doom and also as I
mentioned yesterday and as we've
mentioned a few times on the channel
we've heard that there is going to be a
universe where the X-Men ruled the
universe and Magneto is in charge and
Professor X and the other X-Men are on
his side well this could be that
Universe the new Earth slash battle
World After All if Magneto and Professor
Xavier team up together that's a really
hard Duo to beat like insanely hard to
beat and if the other X-Men follow
Professor X and follow Magneto then
that's a big team that you have to
defeat to get control over that world so
that is probably the case Magneto and
Professor X on the rest of the X-Men
rule this world this new battle world so
I'm thinking Magneto would essentially
kind of take the role that Dr Doom has
in the comics and this is probably where
problems arise for Wolverine and
Deadpool because of of course they're
not going to want to play by their games
play by their rules but again the
question is why is the TVA collecting
Heroes and putting them on one world we
could theorize about this all day but
like I mentioned before there are a few
options that make sense one is that Kang
could simply have the TVA do this Kang
realizes what is happening it's a direct
order from Kang to the TVA telling them
that instead of pruning all these
timelines go to these timelines collect
the biggest baddest best heroes from
them and put them all on one planet one
universe and again there could be
several different reasons of why he
could be doing this he could one simply
be doing it as a muse he could simply
just want to rule over the universes the
multiverse's most powerful Heroes and
much like in the comics he could simply
have them fight each other just like the
beyonder did after all we do know from
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania that
Kang has defeated many Avengers and we
can assume X-Men as well so perhaps
capturing the multiverses Mightiest
Heroes and putting them all on the same
world together other is simply a muse
for Kang or another option is he could
want to use them remember that kangs are
at war with one another yes in
quantumania they presented the Council
of kangs and showed us thousands of
kangs on the same side however don't be
fooled each and every individual Kang
Wants To Rule The Multiverse for himself
and you can already tell that the leader
is the king Trio don't trust each other
plus not to mention they exiled the king
that we saw in quantumania and the first
multiversal war and almost the
destruction of the entire Multiverse
itself was caused by Kings fighting each
other so it would make sense that if a
king could he would recruit the
universe's mightiest heroes and villains
to fight alongside of him and they can
see obviously the power that he has with
the TVA and the destruction of all these
other universes he could simply tell
them hey you're gonna fight for me or
I'm gonna kill you and destroy all of
your universes if they aren't already
and he could also promise them that
they'll rule the Multiverse with him
they'll be his generals and when they
conquer the Multiverse together they
will get the rewards of course if Kang
tells them that I doubt he actually
means it but you could definitely see
how he could use that Army but another
reason that the TVA might actually be
doing this is because they themselves
want an army of all these heroes and
villains to take on Kane the Conqueror
because remember Loki season 2 is going
to expose Kang to the TVA they're going
to set out to stop him and we know
Mobius is going to appear in Deadpool 3.
so it would make sense that the TVA
would know at this point in time that
Kang and his variants they're the bad
guys they need to stop them so this
could actually be a plan by the TVA by
Mobius on the others to try to get an
army to fight against him which I think
would be really really cool and this
could be how we get all of these
different variants to appear in secret
Wars we know Deadpool 3 is going to go
right into it it's going to set it up
and this would be a perfect way to set
it up but let us know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below do you like this idea do you not
like this idea let us know what you
think don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest MCN you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf